the gay dating app Grindr released a
bunch of very naughty emoji this week
they're pretty LGBT cute I know they are
they're pretty great I'm not gay not
that cool but people do tell me that I
am a lot on Twitter so cool or gay okay
okay yeah let me didn't translate this
just a little bit okay this log the
sunrise is for when you have morning
wood all right this emoji of a peach
with a knife and fork is for when you're
talking about for eating all right now
these all look dirty but emoji can have
many interpretations so comedians what
is a safe for work explanation of one of
these new Grindr emoji Jessica let's
start with you
yeah the guy in the leather he is
reminding you that you have village
people in your area people your fun Sam
the bearded guy here is a reminder that
zach galifianakis has just been attacked
by a grizzly okay hi Brian
the eggplant must be this long to get
into my casserole that's only three
inches
[Applause]